In the sixth episode of Star Trek: Picard,
Jean-Luc Picard and the crew of the La Sirena
reach the Borg Artifact, and Soji finally
begins to learn the truth about who and what
she is.
From Voyager nods to visuals pulled straight
from Deep Space Nine, here are all the Easter
eggs and references in "The Impossible Box."
Early on in "The Impossible Box," as the La
Sirena nears the former Borg cube now known
as "The Artifact," Picard instructs the computer
in his study to search for the terms "the
Artifact," "treaty," and "the Borg."
When he sits down to reluctantly scroll through
the results, several of the images on which
Picard chooses to linger are easily identifiable.
There's the ex-Borg, Hugh, both when he first
came aboard the Enterprise on The Next Generation,
and then again as he appears in Picard; several
shots of ex-Borg in the midst of their reclamation
procedures; and of course, Picard as Locutus
of Borg.
But there are also several other quick glimpses
of search results you may not have recognized.
The first was a shot of a Federation ship
firing on a Borg cube and seemingly doing
some damage, which could have been from the
battle at the opening of Star Trek: First
Contact.
The next image is of the Romulan Continuing
Committee, which is taken straight from the
Deep Space Nine episode in which a character
becomes entangled in a Tal Shiar plot.
There is also a brief image of the Paris skyline
in the year 2372, which was taken from the
Deep Space Nine episode "To the Death."
In that episode, the DS9 crew has to destroy
an Iconian Gateway, a technological portal
which could instantly transport people over
enormous distances, which is very similar
to the device Picard and Soji use to escape
the Romulans at the end of "The Impossible
Box."
As the La Sirena nears the Borg Artifact,
Raffi turns on the charm to contact her old
friend and Starfleet contact, Emmy, requesting
diplomatic credentials for Picard.
But Emmy refuses at first, saying that the
Romulans are in a "250-year bad mood."
If you're wondering what happened to the Romulans
two and a half centuries ago to make them
so cranky, well, that's about the time they
first came in contact with humans in 2152.
Just a few years later, in 2156, the Earth-Romulan
war began, which only lasted for four years,
but is still having repercussions over 200
years into the future.
The end of the war was marked by the establishment
of the Romulan neutral zone in 2160, and led
directly to the formation of the United Federation
of Planets in 2161.
Given the Romulans' long-running tension with
the Federation, it's no wonder that they're
still in a bad mood.
When Hugh mentions in "The Impossible Box"
that the former Borg on the Artifact refer
to themselves as "xBs," Picard wonders out
loud at the reason for renaming themselves.
Hugh explains,
"A new name can be the first step to a new
identity.
I learned that on the Enterprise all those
years ago."
The lesson Hugh is referring to took place
in the episode where he first appeared on
The Next Generation, titled "I Borg.”
At first, Hugh doesn't see himself as an individual,
but as a member of the Collective, referring
to himself only as "we," and telling the crew
that he is "Third of Five."
However, after Geordi and Beverly explain
the purpose of names to him, he decides he
wants one for himself.
"Do I have a name?"
"Do you want one?"
"A name."
Adopting his own name marks the beginning
of Hugh's ability to think of himself in terms
of "I," not "we," and ultimately leads to
his lifelong mission to free and rehabilitate
other Borg.
In part, Hugh's job as the Executive Director
of the Borg Reclamation Project involves him
overseeing the rehabilitation efforts of the
traumatized ex-Borg who are trying to recuperate
from their assimilation.
However, as he shares with Picard, even after
the xBs have gone through reclamation, they
still aren't accepted by free society.
Hugh says that the xBs remain the most hated
people in the galaxy, just as helpless and
enslaved as before, but that now, their queen
is a Romulan.
This is a clear nod to the Borg Queen that
Picard himself encountered in Star Trek: First
Contact.
The Queen was the one who directed the Borg's
actions, and she revealed in First Contact
that it was her idea to assimilate Picard
as "Locutus."
Rather than have just another nameless Borg
drone, the Queen had hoped Picard would serve
as her counterpart.
However, Picard's resistance proved not to
be futile after all, forcing the Queen to
abandon her plan.
When Picard finds Soji alive on the Artifact,
it's great news for the two of them, but not
so good for Raffi, who had placed a bet with
Rios that Picard's target would already be
dead.
"You owe me two strips of latinum.
The twin's still alive."
While latinum has popped up here and there
across multiple Star Trek shows, it was most
frequently mentioned in Deep Space Nine as
the preferred currency of the Ferengi Alliance,
and specifically of Quark, the Ferengi bartender
on the space station.
Latinum is often referenced in the Ferengi
Rules of Acquisition, around which Ferengi
society is structured.
"Rule of Acquisition number 102."
"Good lad!"
When Picard and Hugh enter Soji's quarters,
a voice can be heard in the background announcing
that "Sectors 5-8 through 5-21 are temporarily
closed due to detected chronometric activity."
In Star Trek: First Contact, the controlled
emission of chronometric particles is what
allowed the Borg to travel back in time and
assimilate Earth, which forced the Enterprise
crew to chase after them and re-establish
the original timeline.
But in addition to the chronometric activity,
the specific sectors that are mentioned may
also have a hidden meaning.
In the fifth season of Star Trek: The Next
Generation, episode 8 and episode 21 were
both directed by Cliff Bole.
While neither of these episodes feels particularly
relevant to "The Impossible Box," the same
cannot be said of two other Bole-directed
episodes of The Next Generation: "The Best
of Both Worlds," parts I and II.
Those, of course, are the episodes in which
Picard is assimilated by the Borg and becomes
Locutus, an event which was heavily referenced
in "The Impossible Box."
When Picard, Soji, Hugh, and Elnor find themselves
trapped in the former Borg Queen's chamber,
Hugh is able to use his Collective memories
of the area to grant them access to the Queen's
failsafe escape route.
It turns out the Queen has a spatial trajector,
an instant teleportation device with a wide
range, which Hugh says was built from technology
the Borg acquired after assimilating Sikarians.
Star Trek fans have actually seen a spatial
trajector once before: on the Star Trek: Voyager
first season episode "Prime Factors."
In the episode, Captain Janeway and her crew
encounter the Sikarians, whose teleportation
technology has the potential to cut their
decades-long journey home in half.
"I've just been to Alastria and back.
Alastria is 40,000 light years away.”
However, the Sikarians are reluctant to share
their technology due to their own version
of the Prime Directive, which prohibits them
from interfering in the development of less
advanced cultures.
Sadly, it seems that the technology the Sikarians
were so protective of in Voyager has since
been taken out of their hands by force.
Although Picard was certainly grateful for
the escape, he'd probably be the first to
agree that the cost was too high.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Trek
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one